my chairman so if you're ready
uh we can go live thank you very much
yes i'm ready thank you miss bird
um
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen uh
members and members of the public
um welcome to this licensing
subcommittee held on monday the 28th of
september
uh we are sitting here under the
auspices of the licensing act
2003 to hear an application made
under the act my name is councillor mark
durham and i have been appointed the
chairman for this meeting
this meeting is held under nations which
came into effect on the fourth of april
in response to the kovid 19 situation
and there are just a few new
housekeeping rules to run through
first of all could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee
this will help to reduce background
noises and avoid
any unintentional disturbances this
meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate you
wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used
for questions or any other purposes or
comment
please do not use the raise hand
function as this may not be available
on all member devices when speaking
and referring to the agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph
number and lastly if members need to
leave the meeting at any point
please make this known and use the chat
function to signify
that you need to leave the meeting now
i'd like to ask officers taking part in
this meeting to introduce themselves
starting this time with mr quelch
afternoon chairman um simon quelch
and i'm the lead legal specialist
and the legal advisor for the sub
subcommittee this afternoon
thank you mr quilch miss latimer
thank you chair my name is lacey latimer
and i'm a licensed officer for malden
council and i'll be presenting the
committee report this afternoon
miss bird thank you chairman i'm tara
bird i'm committed services
officer for the meeting thank you thank
you very much and are there any other
malden officers present please
yeah my name is damian geller i'm the
lead specialist for the community at
malden district council
thank you mr keller uh in the absence of
any other officers
um miss bird could you now carry out a
roll call of the members to confirm who
is in attendance here please
yes of course chairman and members if i
call your names could you just indicate
um by turning your camera on your
microphone whether you're present please
and so starting with um council durham's
obviously here council
g'day afternoon tara presents it's
unusual
being first with my surname
confused matters thank you councillor
stilts
good afternoon sarah um i'm president
thank you thank you very much
and council mrs thompson good afternoon
tara
everybody um yes i'm present thank you
thank you very much
and could i ask chairman if there's any
members in attendance if they could
introduce themselves please
i can see councillor bassinger and
councillor morris um
in attendance thank you very much
council investor thank you
good afternoon brittany morris in the
house
thank you council morris
thank you very much members and officers
um have we any apologies
uh please miss bird no apologies
thank you thank you very much uh next
item on the agenda is the closure of
interest
so to disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests on
non-pecuniary interests
relating to the items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
and members you're also reminded that
you are required to disclose any such
interests
as soon as they become aware should the
nieser ride need arise throughout the
meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate and
i will invite you to speak uh i will go
first
in the interests of openness and
transparency it is not
uh a peculiarly on non-binary interest
i have been a personal license holder uh
for approximately 30 years
any other declarations of interest
no one else has indicated they wish to
speak
excellent thank you very much indeed so
now we move on to item five
uh the application uh
for a premises license at the jolly
sailor church street malden
essex um so
i refer everybody present to the egg
memoir that you'll find on page three
of the agenda pack which details the
procedure we have to follow
at this meeting can i ask everyone
that everyone has read the officers
report on appendices and the evidence
submitted albeit it's
extremely lengthy which was circulated
prior to the meeting
should anyone have any late
documentation in support of a rep
representation or the application this
may only be introduced with the consent
of all parties
members are you happy just to confirm
that you have been supplied with the
full documentation
thank you very much members so um just
to just to reaffirm members
um because this is a very important
meeting if you wish to speak
please make this known uh and uh i'll
come to you
um hopefully in turn it's only a small
number of members so hopefully
um hopefully we we can keep it in order
um i'd be very much appreciative keep
your points
clear and succinct um
right oh so um
can i now ask a person's present at the
meeting to introduce themselves
uh and i think we're going to start with
mr geller
hello there so my name is damian geller
i'm the
lead specialist for malden district
council communities
thank you mr geller and for the uh
information of members
uh mr geller is referred to as the
applicant on this
occasion uh now we have mr celie
yes thank you chair uh mr seeley i'm a
solicitor at a firm called ellison's uh
and i'm representing
um the premises license holders uh today
mr and mrs brett mr brett is here i'm
going to swing my
camera around we are socially distancing
so apologies for that but hopefully you
can see him
roughly there good afternoon good
afternoon mr brett
okay thank you very much indeed now i'd
like to call on miss latimer to provide
us with a brief outline
of this application please
thank you chair the committee is
requested to consider an application
made by environmental health
to review a premises license under
section 51 of the licensing act 2003
and have regard to representations made
during the consultation period that
followed
in line with the promotion of the
following license activities namely
the prevention of crime and disorder the
prevention of public nuisance the
protection of children from harm
there are no recommendations but in
considering the representations received
and what is appropriate for the
promotion of the licensing objectives
the steps the committee can take are
outlined in paragraph 4.2
the jolly sailor is a public house which
is situated on the corner of the height
and church street a copy of the premises
license is attached as appendix a
on the 10th of august 2020 the licensing
department received an
application for a review of a premises
license from
environmental health for the jolly
sailor on the grounds of the prevention
of crimea disorder the prevention of
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm
a copy of the full application for a
review of the premises license is
attached as appendix b
the application has been properly made
in accordance with the licensing act
2003
and all procedures correctly followed
the public notice was properly displayed
and copies of all
application served on the premises
license holder and responsible
authorities
the application was also advertised on
the council's website
during the consultation period responses
have been received
from five members of the public i have
attached these responses as appendix c
the current license was grandfathered in
2005 from the magistrates
the licence holders are mr allen brett
and mrs kerry brett whom the
whom the review application was served
the designated premises supervisor is mr
allen daniel brett who has been in this
role since the 6th of september 2019.
the licensing authority is required to
hold a hearing to consider the review of
an
application and any relevant
representations made
the committee is required to give
appropriate weight to the review
application
representations including supporting
information presented by all parties
the guidance issued under section 182 of
the license act 2003 the council's
statement of licensing policy
and any steps if any that are
appropriate to promote the ford
licensing objectives
having considered those relevant matters
the licensing committee can take
such of the following steps if any as it
considers appropriate for the promotion
of the licensing objectives
to modify the conditions of the license
to exclude any of the license activities
from the scope of the license
to remove the designated premises
supervisor to suspend the license for a
period not exceeding three months
to revoke the licence and for for the
purpose the conditions of the licence
are modified
if any of them are altered or omitted
from
any new condition added
it should be noted that clear visa must
be given for the decision any additional
or modified conditions should be
practical and enforceable
the applicant for the review the
premises license holder and any person
who made relevant representations
would have the right of the appeal to
the magistrate's court on what
on one of the grounds provided in
schedule 5 to the licensing act 2003
in addition to determining the
application in accordance with the
legislation members
have must have regard to the common law
rules of national justice
provisions of human rights act
consideration in section 17 of the crime
disorder act
i would invite members to read point
3.14 and 3.15 of my report
members i hope you've had the
opportunity to me by report before this
meeting there are a number of relevant
sections
contained within the statement of
licensing policy that i would like to
draw to your attention
the list is lengthy and therefore are
summarized so that you can take
into account of these later
at 74 regarding crime and disorder
licence holders should demonstrate the
impact factors
a list is included below
at 81 the licensing authority interprets
the term public nuisance in relation to
its
meaning in common law this includes
issues such as noise nuisance light
pollution
smells litter and anti-social behavior
where these interfere with public as a
class of citizens and not merely one
person
at 82 applicants should demonstrate in
an operating schedule
the measures that have been identified
to prevent public nuisance
relevant the individual style and
characteristics of their premises and
events
at 85 when addressing the issue of the
provincial public nuisance
an applicant should demonstrate the
impact factors that impact on the
likelihood of public nuisance that have
been
considered although not definite a list
of factors is included in my report
at 92 although the licensed
grandfathered applicants should identify
suitable and sufficient measures
that will be implemented and maintained
to protect children from harm
relevant to the individual style and
characteristic of their premises and
events
at 83 whilst children may be adequately
protected from harm
by the action taken to protect adults
there may also be
special consideration and no policy can
and says anticipate every situation when
addressing the issue of protecting
children from harm
a licence holder should demonstrate
these factors which may include
a list a list and a list is
for a list is provided in my report
at 94 an example list of control
measures is referred to
in assisting licence holders to put
safeguards in place to protect children
and i would recommend members have
regards to this list
contained in my report
members must consider the
representations made by the applicant
and any other relevant representations
consider the licensing objectives
statutory guidance and the licensing
policy
and determine the application as stated
at paragraph 3.10
members are reminded that they have the
following options if they
if they decide when determining this
application their options are set out
below
an appeal against the review decision
may be made within 21 days following
receipt of the notification of the
decision by the licensing committee
by the license holder environmental
health or any other person making
relevant representations
that concludes my report thank you chair
thank you very much um miss latimer um
i would now like to invite the applicant
mr geller would you like to make an
opening statement
mr geller thank you councillor don
hello everyone hello members um as um
mentioned earlier my name is i'm the
lead supporter of the malden district
council
and what that means is that i've got
functional control over environmental
services housing and waste management
and so as such when cases reach a
sufficient level of concern they're
escalated to me
for more robust action in relation to
the jolly sailor public house again as
mentioned before
it's a premises that's on the corner of
the higher than church street
and its main building was undergoing
refurbishment at the time
where in this investigation concerns
were raised
so i first became aware of issues
regarding the journalistic sailor around
the 18th of may
2020 and this was just around the time
when the government had offered guidance
in relation to pubs providing takeaway
services as a means of
carrying on their business
in order to facilitate this the licensee
chose to erect two gazebos
on an area of land referred to as the
upper deck from here food and drink was
sold to members of the public and when i
say food and drink
this also includes the sale of alcohol
and i refer specifically to
exhibits dg 14 19 30 and 31 as examples
of this type of
behavior since commencement of that
particular
type of service the council received
numerous complaints from elected members
and
members of the public in relation to
social distancing
increased in litter public nuisance and
lack of ppe being used by staff when
serving
now representatives from the for the
jolly sailor claimed that there was a
lack of
investigative uh investigations in
relation to these concerns
but what i would say is um we are
talking about
uh new legislative requirements that
came in around the time of kovid
which slowed and changed the way certain
things had to be investigated and
things were investigated and engagement
was put first
and we um we dealt with
the complaints by way of initial conduct
initial engagement
with people um including
the licensee holder including
complainants externally we did carry out
additional patrols and we also
issued guidance to uh to the licensing
mr brett
um and this was contained within exg22
and in terms of the extra patrols and
the extra
picture and evidence that we we gathered
that was uh covered across exdg
27 to 28 and 30.
um there's a suggestion that there was
no causal link
and what we're saying is basically that
the method of service delivery was such
and bearing in mind you have to remember
at the time um that we were in
in the case of a national lockdown um
most premises were shut
um people were allowed to go out for a
certain amount of time to
um to exercise and the operation of the
jolly sailor
was such that it was the only draw in
town for that area of the hive
and therefore it provided a excuse for
people to come
and gather and remain within a certain
area
um in terms of so we do believe that
there's a causal link there
in terms of the mitigations um
you know advice that we offered there
was suggest that we didn't we didn't
sort of
offer advice well you know we did it's
contained within exg22
um in terms of the policing powers
you know no actions were taken and so on
i would say that
um we we don't have the the police's
details in relation to any fps that are
issued but we
we did certainly when we started to get
complaints regarding this this area
uh we did start to look at uh additional
ways of controlling some of the nuisance
that we were
reports that we were receiving at the
time and this included the consideration
of dispersal zones um
looking at the possibility of public
space protection orders um
and also other mitigating factors in
terms of what could be done to try and
control the operation that you know the
jolly sailor
was carrying out
in summary we believe that
the serving areas of the upper deck and
the ability to provide off sales during
the height of the lockdown is acted
uh as an enticement as a draw for people
coming into the hive
um because it provides easy access to
alcohol and food
uh within a fairly you know within a
pleasant setting
um and the operation the setup kind of
gives the impression of an open-air
bar um
while other premises uh opted to remain
closed and examples of this again are
contained within exdg 14
19 30 and 31
we um offered advice to mr brett on the
10th of june 2020 however we continue to
receive complaints regarding lack of ppe
and people gathering in the locality um
and in terms of the lucky lack of ppe
used by mr brett
by mr brett's staff uh this is
referenced in exg26
uh but it's also uh in evidence in his
own
uh picture evidence of page 81 and page
91 which shows
some of his own members of staff in the
serving area without any protective
equipment on
we also continue to receive public
complaints
[Music]
and that's referenced within ex dg24 and
others as well
and we believe that without new
conditions to mitigate how the jolly
solo operates going forward particularly
in relation to the upper deck
we'll continue to see instances uh and
complaints of litter
drunkenness and concerns regarding
social distancing
um this is especially concerning
obviously
in light of the new um covered increases
that that's being reported
and in terms of the more rules about how
people may gather
and we believe that new conditions or
prohibitions to the jolly sailors
license will help the council in this
endeavors to try and mitigate the
alcohol-related nuisance that occurs in
in the locality
um to offer additional protections to
the jolly sailors on staff by perhaps
causing them to really focus on making
sure that ppe is used amongst staff
um and to improve the safety of for
local residents and passes by during the
pandemic
so sorry that's my summary in conclusion
thank you thank you very much
uh mr geller um uh
i understand there is no um nobody from
the police do you have any other
witnesses that you would wish to call
before um
members get an opportunity to ask you
questions uh no
this is for me uh members before we move
on to
um the license holder you have the
opportunity to pose mr geller questions
um
please make sure they're open questions
not leading questions
uh and related to um the evidence that
you've heard
members please indicate via the
via the chat function mr uh councillor
siddal
thank you chairman uh
mr uh in terms of
the visits by yourself or by other
council representatives who went down to
the premises and looked at what was
going on there
and what exact site did you have
personally
in terms of the ppe
um again is that something
that used
or we have exact evidence in terms of
when it was used and when it wasn't used
and do we have
any are there any police cases are there
any is there
any complaints from parents
about the effect that it had on children
because obviously
that's one of the areas that we're being
asked to look at
so what what issues do we have exactly
in terms of evidence
that children are affected by the
operation of the jolly sailor
okay i'll do my best to answer those in
relation to who visited
um the jolly roger was visited by
two community engagement officers um
you'll have to bear with me and i'll
just get you the dates
that's right so i referred to my
evidence bundle um
paragraph 28 and 29 so the 16th and the
6th
uh patrolling officer from the community
engagement team um
attended and that's exg27
you've also got a video uh supplied by a
council contractor
from the on the 15th to the 6th that's
exg26 and those
are the two video clips um
and in terms of photos that were
supplied i had photos that were supplied
by
one of the community engagement officers
um and that was
on the 17th of the 6th ex dg28
so there was one by contractor on the
15th and the 6th
one by community engagement officers on
the 16th of the 6th
followed up by photos on the 17th of the
6th
so those those are the visits that were
done in terms of myself
um out of hours um
i have done uh a drive-by of the local
area
um so i am familiar with the layout um
and i've seen some of the bits and
pieces i've got
that have gone on there um
but because this was out of hours out of
official capacity i
i haven't included that
[Music]
in terms of personal protective
equipment
um the evidence that we're relying on in
terms of personal protective equipment
i'm not saying personal protective
equipment wasn't used at all
um there are instances and you can see
from from mr brett's
own pictures there are some instances
where they are in use but then there's
other pictures where
it's not in use at all um now
the the guidance in relation to
protective equipment and its use
in relation to kovid there are some
exemptions
some of these exemptions have been
tidied up and tightened particularly in
relation to the latest
round of guidance given by the
government but nevertheless all of that
is contained within the um the official
gardens that
you know when serving customers uh
protection should be provided both the
staff working next to each other and
also
some sort of uh barrier for for members
of the public
um that might be being served
so so there is there is guidance in
relation to ppe that we've
referred to and there were instances
where we've seen breaches of that
um and in relation to complaints
regarding children
um we haven't received any specific
complaints
um from residents or
or or people passing through that
specifically mentioned children what we
have done notice though the reason why
that was included
was because when we look at the pictures
it's quite clear that the hive is a
gathering area for all sorts of
different people
it's a very scenic area and there are
lots of families going through their
uh families with young children and
again
i would draw attention to the fact this
was at the height of lockdown
when you know um transmission fears were
at the highest
um and most
areas um of malden seem to be able to
maintain social distance in
as well as could be expected but within
the highs it was very very
very busy um and that's with families
you know and families with your young
children
um you've seen through some of the
pictures that are included within the
evidence bundle
um that there were large groups of of
young teenagers there were large groups
of adults there were large groups of
parents with children and that's the
reason why they were included because
they that was they were one of the risk
factors basically
okay could i come back please chairman
of course yes of course councillor civil
yeah
um in terms of the videos
i presume the one in the van is the
contractor
yes what's the relationship between
the driver of that van and
the business owners of the jolly sailor
is there because if you watch that video
right at the end yeah the worst possible
language
is used on that video in reference
to the people at the pub
so i've got concern that the person who
supplied that video
has supplied that in video in a
subjective and not an objective manner
so do you know of any difficulties or
any relationship
between the driver of that van and the
owners and operators of the pub
no i'm not aware of any connection
between the driver of that van and um
the the pub um what what i would say is
as far as i'm aware in terms of the
business types of the contractor
and the pub that there is no um
immediate link that there's nothing that
associates uh
the two business that would bring them
into connection with each other as far
as i'm aware
so i i was extremely shocked when i
listened to that video
because the person on it uses the worst
possible
swear word yeah no i appreciate that but
that is
how the evidence was um supplied
unfortunately and in order to give a
you know a unredacted
uh view um that that was the comment
so in terms of the business operating
and in terms of
what they were doing what they were
doing wasn't illegal
which one so you're referring to the
jolly sailor so in terms of jolly sailor
in terms of
say it wasn't illegal but what they were
weren't doing was they
in your view is they weren't operating
in the correct way is that correct
that's right yeah so
um again i i mean i've tried i've tried
to make it clear in the evidence that um
the jolly sailor isn't wholly to blame
for everything that goes on down there
that's not what we're trying to say what
we are trying to say is that
the method in which they choose they
chose to operate this
um serving the serving area from the
upper deck
um did cause and contribute to people
gathering in that area
um it caused an increase in littering um
and perhaps at the worst time when
there's there's no services for people
to use people limited in what
buildings they can access um people were
feeling trapped because of lockdown and
obviously that was the ones
place where they could get release and
perhaps the worst place that they could
get released from from lockdown okay
thank you mr gayla thank you councillor
uh
councillor uh any other members of the
um committee wish to cross-examine mr
keller
mr geller i would just like to ask if
during this period uh
the jolly sailor was open and operating
albeit outside
during this time was uh was the the pub
just around the corner which is visible
from the jolly sailor that is the
queen's head
were they operating in any capacity at
all
not as far as we were aware um all the
evidence
and the reports i've got have indicated
they they were closed
thank you very much uh and i just want
to to
be clear on the legal position regarding
ppe
um we are aware from the latest
government guidelines that now
uh it is a legal requirement for retail
and hospitality
staff to wear uh face masks but at the
time
uh that wasn't the case um so
in in effect um they weren't contravene
or the staff weren't contravening
uh the ppe uh guidelines government
guidelines
and um during and at the same time
the customers at the pub again
were not required to if they were in the
process of consuming
um food and drink as i understand it
could you confirm that's correct please
yes that is correct thank you very much
indeed
uh any other members wish to i'm going
to come to i know mr seeley wishes to
cross examine mr geller which is your
entitlement sir but i'm going to come to
mr quelch first please
um thank you chairman uh just a point um
the it's only the committee
um mr seeley and obviously
mr geller that actually have
the evidence itself and so
when mention is made of the evidence
bundle like for example
exhibit numbers i think it might be
useful just
for that particular person so if the
public are listening in
to know just exactly what that document
is
perhaps in a sentence because that
is not available to the public just so
that the public can follow
what's happening more easily
sensible guidelines thank you mister and
maybe
perhaps chairman i could just ask just
for the sake of clarity if you think
if you think this is helpful if not then
you'll say it's not
um uh what one of the
licensing objectives is of course
that's in question here is um
the matter of crime and public dis
disorder prevention of crime and public
disorder and and the other one is public
private public nuisance prevention of
public nuisance and
prevention of of of harm to children
i don't know whether it's helpful
chairman if actually mr
mr gun actually sets out exactly
that the main points so that everyone
understands and then it
may help mr seeley in his questions as
well
um each particular point
that he's saying there is for example
what crimes he's saying were committed
or what public disorder or what he fears
may actually happen in terms because
there's prevention of crime as well
and the same with the other two headings
i don't know if you think that's helpful
chairman
um it is uh mr quelch because i i think
that
in order to avoid a misunderstanding we
are we are not
here to um make decisions
whether government guidelines have been
broken
uh whether in respect of ppe etc etc
because those are completely separate
laws
we are here to determine this uh in
respect of the licensing act 2003
and it is a um a prerequisite
of license holders they must operate
their premises
uh in uh in line with the four
licensing objectives so that is what we
are here to decide not whether
or not they have breached the law in
respect of ppe
so to be very clear the question we need
to ask themselves is
by the actions that we have seen and had
evidence
to support or otherwise have these
objectives been breached
one the prevention of crime and disorder
two public safety three the prevention
of public nuisance or
for the protection of children from harm
that is what we are
actually here to decide um
so uh mr keller i don't know if you have
any further comments before i come to mr
seeley
um i can refer to
um my actual the actual application
where i've tried to set out
uh against those headings what it is we
feel
uh has has occurred has been you know uh
has caused us to put the application
review in perhaps if i go through that
that might be helpful
that would certainly be useful yeah
thank you so in relation to the
prevention of crime and disorder
we believe that the availability of
alcohol served by the jolly sailor led
to a rise in littering
and waste within the locality now
despite claims that
litter was being picked up by the
licensee staff the council did notice an
increase in deposits of alcohol-related
litter
along the hive um particularly along the
front of the john lee sailor which
resulted in the need to provide
additional
waste receptacles there have been
reports as well of people under the
influence of alcohol attempting to board
moored vessels without authorization and
acts of public urination drunkenness and
aggressive behavior
which required police attendance and
which affected local residents so in
terms of
prevention of crime and disorder that's
what we're suggesting with the concerns
in relation to the prevention of public
nuisance the government provided
uh guidelines and concerns to social
distancing which continue to remain in
place and indeed have been bolstered
now the aesthetic nature of the area and
the availability of food and alcohol for
the jolly sailor over the period of
lockdown did draw large gatherings to
the local area
in a manner which breached those
guidelines and we believed represented a
health hazard
the government guidance for the
operation of takeaways um
also provided uh advice on the use of
personal protective equipment
and that included fixtures fittings um
for both the public and and
staff now despite assurances from the
landlord the council believe the jolly
sailors adherence to the advice
um was very loose and it represented a
risk to um
to the safety of staff and also to the
public uh
and therefore lessened at the mitigation
um
for kobe transmission reports also
received alleged jolly sailors playing
loud music on a number of occasions in a
way which
encouraged the party atmosphere to occur
on the highest
um now obviously this is an allegation
if um you know this would be in breach
of the government guidance at the time
which stated that people
um accessing the area should be
encouraged to leave at the earliest
opportunity and obviously if you're
playing music in a way that sort of
contains people in an area
um then obviously that's a concern and
there were additional complaints
regarding
um loud music from from uh local
residents
um and and concerns regarding people
being under the influence of alcohol
and i've referred to again the attempt
to board more
moored vessels and the public urination
so in terms of
prevention of public nuisance that's the
concerns we had there
and although i've mentioned it briefly
i'll just go through it again
in terms of the prevention of harm for
um to children the hive is a popular
part of malden town center and it's a
popular walkthrough for young families
and people with dogs
at the manner in which the jolly sailor
operated encouraged people to congregate
in the locality
and as such the council believes that
this rep represented an increase
to the risk of kobe transmission through
the lack of ppe and the lack of social
distancing
um and as such the council believe that
this also represented an increased risk
to children and young families
passing through the area
so that that thank you thank you mr
geller
members i'll give you one last
opportunity on the basis of what we've
most recently heard uh any other
questions you want to ask mr geller
before we go to mr seeley
not from me thank you chairman thank you
members
uh mr seeley thank you for being patient
so it's uh your this is your opportunity
to cross examine the evidence that has
been given by mr geller before you come
to uh your support of the license holder
submission
thank you chair um mr
can we just start with um some very
sort of basic information um you've
produced a
bundle of documents um much of which are
apparently email complaints and and
items of that nature
what's not apparent and i understand why
because of rules on
action and what have you is how many
individuals
those complaints ultimately emanated
from are you able to tell us that
um
i would say it would be
more than four more than four and the
reason why i can't give you a different
number i can certainly go back and tally
it out but just off the top of my head i
know there was more than
it was more than four um and when you
say more than four do you mean um
four individuals from four different
households or four individuals
potentially from one two three
households
no no i believe four individuals across
completely unrelated
okay um now um just a a few
hopefully uncontroversial things that i
just want to um
give you the opportunity to disagree
with if um if need be
um so mr brett been the licensee of the
jolly sailor for over 31 years you
accept that do you
yes yep and certainly since um 2005
since the council has been
um uh has been responsible for licensing
matters
will you would you accept that there
have been no uh cause to take any action
against the
premises license yes i believe so
there's nothing that i i was referenced
on
on any of the documents i've got thanks
um
and then one other general thing about
the lockdown
you you i think use the phrase if you'll
excuse me for saying so but you use the
phrase lockdown rather loosely
um in your presentation i think i'm
right in saying and again correct me if
i'm wrong that
um this these allegations they cover the
period the 15th of june to the 20th 15th
of may to the 27th of june
and it was two days before the 15th of
may
the start of this period that the rules
were eased weren't they and so what
happened on the 13th of may
was that individuals were allowed to
engage in unlimited
public exercise they were allowed to
meet one and
one other person outside but they had to
maintain two meter distancing so we're
not talking about the very height of
the lockdown is that is that right no
we're not talking at the very heart of
lockdown we are talking about the the
tail end of it as businesses started to
become
reopened great thank you and
and clearly you've accepted um that
um the hive is a very um picturesque and
popular area it's going to attract
people isn't it
um a on a sunny day at b in a period
when the height of lockdown has been
eased
um and people are allowed outside again
yes yeah great thank you um
and do you accept the general
proposition that that i i've
made in um our representations
that um whether you like it or not the
jolly sailor has no jurisdiction
over what happens um when customers
leave
its premises so it can't enforce any
legal powers regarding littering it
can't enforce social distancing rules
it can't control new noise nuisance and
it can't control where people decide to
urinate
is that fair enough yes the only caveat
i would add to that
is no other businesses were in operation
at that time and therefore they were
that the main draw there that so
anything that anything that did happen
there um from the information that we
had
um maybe a factor in that
a draw an enticement oh okay well let me
let me just come back to you on
that point because i i don't think we
accept
well i know we don't accept that no
other premises were open during this
period
and we cover that in
my representations which members of the
committee can see
at page 52 of the supplemental bundle
that was
um served over the weekend so um
during the period we're talking about
i'm going to put it to you mr geller
that the following premises
were open firstly there were about five
food and soft drink kiosks in and around
the hive
and the marine lake and promenade there
was a seafood
stall that sold food and alcohol
there was an ice cream van which we see
on many many of the photographs which
i'm sure we'll
will feature later on today um there is
the first stop
off license which isn't very far away
there's mold and discount food there's
an m
s there's a co-op and iceland mold and
news agents
tesco's morrisons the sark restaurant
and the mighty oak and they're all
within
well less than a quarter of a mile of
these premises and they were all open
during the period you're talking about
did you accept that i accept that
a lot of those businesses well except
the businesses were open the ones that
you've mentioned
i would say that a lot of those are on
the high street so they're away from
the hive area uh although within walking
distance
um in terms of the um
local businesses operating on the highs
um
as far as the details that we've got
suggested that
um that most of them were closed as far
as i remember
you are correct there is um some sort of
ice cream van
that was present but i don't recall ever
seeing it serve
you know people purchasing from it uh
and certainly within the um
the pictures that i remember seeing i
can't say for sure
if anyone is purchasing or if the van is
in operation or not but yes i accept
that it was present
do you think that the ice cream van
would have hung around there a not
serving and b
just would have hung around there if
nobody was buying ice cream from them
um again with with some of the lockdown
and some of the restrictions i'm not
sure about what
people were um intending to do with
those businesses
uh businesses were trying to figure out
new ways to provide their services
it may have been the case that the ice
cream van was parked up there with the
the owner not being present until he
figured out how what he was going to do
next uh you know he could have been a
local resident
i don't know i don't have that detail so
my apologies i can't answer that
question clearly
okay let me let me come back to you on
on two of those points mr geller because
mr brett lives on the high he lives in
the premises immediately adjacent to the
jolly sailor yes
and his evidence will be and i'll ask
him to confirm this when it's
our opportunity to speak um that
um a the ice cream van was whenever it
was there it was serving
and b that those um five
uh kiosks and the seafood stall that
sold
um food and alcohol were all serving
during the period
um covered by um this application so
if mr um brett confirms that
when it's his opportunity to speak
you'll accept that will you
because you've got nowhere to the
country have you no i mean i would only
refer to the pictures that we've got
that have been supplied
um like i said i can confirm the ice
cream van was present but i i haven't
seen within
the other pictures anything that
indicates these other stools that you
mentioned
right that brings me on to another
point mr geller which is that i can't
see any obvious evidence that in respect
of any of the
allegations that you level at the jolly
sailor that you've done any work to
establish for certain
where the person's allegedly
perpetrating these things actually came
from
in what respect because obviously we
have officers that patrol the area and
you can see people
you know there
in terms of uh the litter that was in in
the immediate area
um yes you're right you can't say a
hundred percent that that bottle came
from the jolly sailor but what you can
say for example
um is that jolly sailor was selling
similar bottles similar produce
um i accept the fact that mr brett has
advised that his um his staff were
trying to list a pick in the area
but obviously we've got pictures that
show litter in the area
so okay well just pausing there then the
the photos that i think you're referring
to mr geller
um are um the ones uh
principally at 30 is that right that's
members of the committee that's starting
at page 44 of the original bundle that
you received
is it am i right about that mr geller um
i'll
just be only a minute i'm just going
through the evidence bundle myself so
i would draw attention to um for example
exdg-14 hang on just okay
pausing there yep right okay um
tell me tell me um of those photographs
there's only one that shows any litter
which of those items do you think uh or
can you show that came from the pub
no i i can't i can't say that i can only
say
items there i can only say there are
items there that may have come from the
pub and that's the same with any piece
of litter that's in that locality
okay where in fact is that photo taken
where yeah where within that locality i
believe
um obviously there's nothing to give a
contextual reference
but i believe it's in reference to uh
church street
okay uh mr seeley i'm going to interject
at this opportunity i
i know the direction of your uh
questioning which i appreciate
however i would like to ask you
how many of the premises that you have
just mentioned
have a premises license that includes
the sale of alcohol for consumption
on the premises
on the premises on the premises
speaking in relation to um i
said the premises license that console
of consumption on the premises
uh and um
and do you accept that a lot of these uh
businesses that you have mentioned for
example the kiosks whereas they may have
been able to be open and trading
because they are not um covered by the
licensing act 2003
they don't have to comply with the
licensing objectives so by bringing them
into this equation
i'm afraid that's uh in my opinion
irrelevant and i would draw members
attention to the photograph
the photographs that have been mentioned
by mr silly on page 46 and 47 which show
the odd bottle uh in flower planters but
i would then bring members attention to
uh the photograph on page 48 where um
i don't think anybody can say that these
people accumulated there are not
related to um the sales that are being
carried out at the jolly sailor
perhaps you'd ask someone answer my
question how many of the premises that
you've mentioned
um have a uh have a
license to sell alcohol on the premises
on the premises um i i would say that
the only
ones would be um bear with me a second
um
be the sark restaurant and probably the
mighty oak
um but what we what we're really talking
about as i understand it chair is the
impact of
off sales in this application not on
sales and
respective off sales all of the
off licenses that i talked about all
those supermarkets they all have
permission for off sales
as did the um the the fish
store the seafood stall um uh on the
promenade which could sell food and
alcohol
yeah i i i think that the point you're
making is perfectly
fair in respect of the complaints about
litter um but
with great respect i don't think that
they're relevant in relation to the
public order
but i will enable you to keep
cross-examining mr geller
thank you chair and apologies if i'm
going slightly off
course um what i was really trying to
bring um
mr geller towards are the photographs at
exd g30 because really these are
the primary photographs um in his bundle
that show uh bottles
alcoholic bottles and glasses
that might potentially come
from um the jolly sailor
and the significance of these
photographs
um chair um which i cover
in our representations is that these
photographs
it's clear from the um uh
the introduction of vxdg30 because it's
an
email center 904 am on the 20th of june
um 2020 is that these photographs were
taken
the morning after this funeral or wake
that happened
um on the key side which was nothing to
do
with the pub and i explained um in our
representations why it was nothing to do
with the pub
and in respect of which the pub closed
early
that evening because of what was going
on down
at the hive the significance being that
because the pub was closed early
there wasn't the usual litter pick by
members of staff because
they left uh because uh the the area was
uh becoming somewhat heated and so to
the extent
that you might in theory be able to um
tie some of these particular bottles and
glasses back to the pub
um there's an explanation for why they
weren't collected
and really that's the critical evidence
as far as i'm concerned in relation to
um the allegation of uh of littering
you know specifically littering that
might be um tied back to the to the
jolly sailor that was what i was trying
to get to but
um perhaps i will um move on
um mr geller um you
touched briefly in your um presentation
um about um
uh some of the powers that
um the council um
or the police uh might have chosen to
take
um but um perhaps
didn't and i just want to ask you about
those in a little bit more detail i
think you said in your presentation
that you don't have um any details
um available for the committee about
whether either the council
um or the police issued any fixed
penalty notices
um during this period for either
breaches of the social distancing rules
or anything to do with public
urination or breach of the peace is that
right
um yeah no we we well so in relation to
modern council
we haven't issued any community
protection notices or any such like
for um those sort of that sort of
behavior
within the higher the area in terms of
the police in relation to both coveted
and anti-social behavior
we don't have any details of any uh
fixed penalty notices they may or may
not have served
okay the the police were presumably
a relevant authority who could have made
relevant representations in support of
this
premises license review weren't they yes
they were copied into the details
yeah and they've chosen presumably not
not to make any representations at all
uh no um while they are aware and i've
referred it through to the community
community safety partnership um
they've issued no um no statements to us
no so as far as we're aware then
neither the council um nor the police
um took any steps that they could have
taken
um in terms of if you like nipping these
problems
in the bud by exercising you know
quasi-like quasi-criminal enforcement
procedures
um i would like to draw attention to one
aspect that might
if you like clarify what the stance was
if you just bear me a minute i just need
to find reference to it within the
evidence bundle
okay we have an email sent on the 26th
of the fifth
uh 2020 from pcso brett fleming
regarding incidents at the jolly sailor
which occurred on the 23rd of the 5th
and the 24th of the 5th and they
like their concerns relate to lack of
social distancing so this is exg-9
um and really i suppose the the picture
from the police was that you know
the kovid hobbit legislation in relation
to social distancing
was uh very new very untested we all
know that
and it leads on the fact that we engage
rather than enforce
and in terms of uh engaging the police
attended and
they they've um fed back and i've
included some uh
some emails from the police licensing
team when they've attended
they've seen certain things but when it
came to
um if you look like enforcement and
following on from the discussions i had
within the community
um safety partnership um
it was it was decided that we would take
action under the licensing conditions
because obviously
in relation to the covert enforcement um
it's a very sort of softly softly
untested approach
um in terms of what was going on at
jolly sailor we were of the mind that
obviously
we needed to do something to just try
and control the services that were being
provided from the upper deck
and that's what really this is focused
on which makes it more of a licensing
issue as opposed to
um if you like an enforcement issue
but but okay but it but if you accept
that
once a customer leaves the
immediate vicinity or other licensed
premises
the jolly sailors license premises which
include the deck area
if you accept that at that point the
jolly sailor has no jurisdiction over
what they do
where they go how they behave then
you can understand can't you the
significance of my questions about in
those circumstances what did
the responsible authorities the council
and the police do
uh to enforce the law
well i mean you can see where the police
have attended and they've engaged
you know engaged in giving words of
advice um in terms of
this together but where have they done
that i i i think you're rather
overstating the case
there i mean we've we've had there's
there's two
um video clips which show
um well some kind of enforcement
officers walking through the highs on
one day and then the next day
uh some people driving past the hive
at no point do any of those clips show
any any
member of the authorities engaging with
anyone about their behavior
whether whether anyone at the jolly
sailor or anyone on the hive
i'd refer to exdg9 um
just wondering you heard about jolly
sailor last night 23rd 24th police were
called to the pub
about selling food and beer from a tent
in the pub sunday it was a disturbance a
fight
um spoke to some local people he said
the landlord
um was a don't mess with me type and he
says he knows all about the law
so the police did engage there well okay
okay i'm going to pause there mr geller
um
sunday there was a disturbance called in
speech marks fight now
the way i read that and correct me if
i'm wrong
is that someone has telephoned the
police and said
there's a fight near the jolly sailor
is that right um let me see
i can only say it just says called about
it might have been a phone call um
he's not saying the police officer is
not saying
i witnessed a fight at the jolly sailor
is he he's saying there was a
disturbance called in
speech
so quite conceivable that the jolly
sailor
in this context is used as um
a local landmark it's near the jolly
sailor
um i mean we haven't we haven't got any
details there have we
no no i agree with that point right okay
so let me read the next sentences to you
i spoke to some local people who said
the landlord comes across as a bit of a
dope mess with me type and says he knows
all about the law he's not very popular
with the locals
he's having lots of work done on the pub
lots of scaffolding etc
where in those sentences does it say
that the police
engaged with mr brett in any way shape
or form about
that no i can see that point it doesn't
say that does it
i can't point to that no and
my my point is that aside from
the letter that you wrote to mr brett
initially and then the exchange of
emails that you had with him
there is no evidence whatsoever of
anybody
um engaging with any other
uh individuals in relation to what was
going on
down at the hive during this period you
accept that i would disagree with that i
would go to exdg8
um email from rachel savile uh police
licensing officer where she actually
says she spoke to
um i've spoken with alan brett the
manager
and the dps of the jolly sailor um
and there's a few different points that
are discussed it looks like a discussion
took place
to difficulties with a neighbor
mr brett advisor he was no longer
selling draft i understand that he tried
to sell draft and didn't work out so he
decided not to sell draft
the discussion there about what what
they were doing at the at the place and
some of the difficulties they were
experiencing it references
um that he feels that you know he's
getting blamed for a lot of issues in
the locality
uh so there was a discussion that took
place quite early on um
involving the police licensing
and what i mean what i'm trying to say
is you know we did have these
discussions and
you know the purpose of this isn't to
try and you know make the jolly sailor
out to be
the absolute villain that's not the
circumstance feed
your video feed okay um well that's an
interesting email that you're referring
to there ex
g8 yeah um
so members of the committee just so you
can follow this if you want to this is
page 14 of the original bundle that you
were
provided with by um committee services
so one of the things that was discussed
um
with pcso pcso
or pc savile on the 26th of may
was the cctv that's available at the
jolly sailor
yeah and it says ct cctv is an operation
this covers the outside areas and the
key and is available to view
if anyone wishes to do so did anybody
at malden district council ever asked to
look at that
no why not um
as we understood it um basically we were
doing patrol or we're intending to do
patrols around that time mr you are
right mr brett did offer the use of cctv
um to be honest
we felt the evidence that we we had and
the information we had access to
um if you like explain the situation
and showed the the situation in the area
quite concisely
um we're not really sure what additional
information um his cctv could have
offered
um but perhaps in hindsight it would
have been better to yeah to try and
access something because i'm gonna
i'm gonna try and put in front of my
screen a live
feed this is a live feed of the keysight
right now yep there are about 35
cameras at um the jolly sailor
about five of which cover the hive area
and nobody has ever come to look at any
of them
now given the seriousness of the
allegations that are in front
of mr brett and the possibility that the
council might take action such as
removing
permission to do off sales would you not
have thought
that that simple measure would have been
an appropriate thing to do to ensure
that
actually what the council had was a full
and proper
understanding of what was going on down
at the hive rather than just sending a
couple of people down a couple of times
and doing
30 seconds or a minute of video no i
think that's being
a bit disingenuous really and the reason
why is because
uh again you know we are talking about
within the lockdown
scenario whether it's you know towards
the end of the situation or whatever but
we are talking about a situation where
it's very difficult for officers to
carry out
direct investigations in the same way we
have to try and get evidence in
sort of different ways or perhaps more
socially distanced ways we were getting
pictures coming in from members of the
public we had our own
officers out patrolling the area i
myself had gone down there when i see tv
would have been additional information
um i don't agree with the
the comment that um
the mata wasn't investigated fully
it was investigated and we've obviously
come to a conclusion and all we're doing
is presenting the the information we've
got and concerns that we've got
regarding
the situation well i think we'll have to
disagree about about whether you
investigated properly or not mr geller
um okay so i i was i was running through
sorry i am going to be as quick as i
possibly can now but this is very
important stuff for the jolly sailor so
i hope you'll
um you'll give me some um leeway uh
on this um so mr geller um
we've we've established that so far as
we know no fixed penalty notices
issued for any offences um do you know
if anyone was arrested for anything
like public urination or breach of the
peace or anything like that
no i don't believe anyone was right okay
tell me then about um the um
the possibility of a dispersal order i
think you said in your presentation that
this was
um briefly um considered
members of the committee it may be
helpful if i just explain
uh something about what dispersal orders
are they are powers
and given to local authorities and the
police under the anti-social behavior
crime and policing act
and where a dispersal order is made
they entitle police officers
and authorized council officers to
direct people who are causing
antisocial behavior or crime to leave an
area covered by a dispersal order
and not return for a period of up to 48
hours so in the context of what we're
talking about here
very very useful powers that could have
been
exercised you accept that mr geller oh
absolutely
i can give you some of the background to
that if you want um
just just to explain how what what the
thinking was at the time if members
would find it useful
yes please yeah okay um yes so
i can advise that dispersal order was
discussed
and the main reason why
it was decided that it wouldn't be the
best method forward is because firstly
um
as mr cd has commented dispersal order
is a police-led power they enact it
and if they decide to enact it it has to
be agreed at inspector level and it has
to be resourced properly
and it was felt at the time that with
everything else that was going on you
have to remember that um
i think a number of officers were
concerned about issues that were going
on in other parts
of essex so chelmsford for example and
there was concern they wouldn't be able
to
fully uh support a dispersal zone
dispersal order
um and within that discussion we talked
about public space protection orders
which i know mr celia is mentioned and
it is something that we are looking at
uh in a medium term to longer term um
and again it came back to the issue of
right well if we if we
can't use a dispersal order if we don't
think we can
you know put it in place at a time when
it's going to be effective
what other powers do we have and again
this has led to the situation we're now
in
okay so um a dispersal order not done
because you because
you the police don't have the resources
to police it
yeah that was that was yeah okay and
and similar reason for not imposing a
public
spaces protection order public space
protection order
um is right so i i
i've i've joined malden council in
january um so that's how long i've been
here for and since that time i've
reviewed
various different bits and pieces um
that are in place
across the district um i
support the um expansion um
of a public space protection order but
that's a big piece of work and it takes
time
uh it takes the gathering of evidence
and again we're talking about a power
that
really takes months to bring into place
not weeks
um and really it was felt that something
needed to be done
sooner rather than later because again
we're talking about the gathering of
people
covered transmission you are absolutely
right a public space protection order
does have very useful powers that we
would consider using
and that's something that's um occurring
in discussion separately but it
certainly wouldn't be something that
would be ready
to uh mitigate some of the circumstances
we've seen uh so far
but but the truth is together as we are
now
just to say i hate to interject uh this
is your opportunity to cross-examine mr
geller
on the evidence that he gave and um
uh i think we are straying into other
what-ifs if you could restrict your
questioning
to uh the evidence that mr geller give
mr brett the license holder will have
his opportunity
okay speak in a minute and and obviously
members
and officers will have the opportunity
to cross-examine
and uh you are a uh a witness i
understand for mr brett so
that will be your opportunity thank you
mr chair
i think i've got about four or five
further questions then and then i will
stop
if they can be fairly fairly they will
be they
um so number one mr geller um
when was the council-owned public toilet
block down on the
hive reopened
um i don't have that date to hand i know
that it was around um
i believe it was towards the end of may
but you'll have to excuse me i don't
have that date to hand i wouldn't want
to mislead anything
um the information i have that it was
around about the 15th of june when
the um lockdown measures were further
eased when non-essential shops were
allowed to open
if that's the case i wouldn't dispute
that okay that's going to have sorted
out any public urination problems isn't
it
um you would hope yeah no the complaint
certainly dropped off around that time
yes
yeah okay um now um
the next thing i i just quickly want to
ask you about so number two
um your um exhibit exdg22
uh the email yes yeah yes so this is the
email that you sent
to uh mr brett um outlining some
measures
um that you thought he should um take
um in response to various issues that
have been raised
by you um and so members of the
committee sorry
if you want to look at this email it's
page 34 of the original bundle that you
were provided with by
um committee services um and what you
said mr geller in the penultimate
paragraph of that email on the 10th of
june was
um to support your social distancing
measures and signage within your
premises boundary the council will be
looking at providing additional signage
along the key
yeah was that done no it's not been done
as yet
um i can only say that it's a point that
i continue to push on
so three months down the line three and
a half months down the line
we don't have the one thing that the
council said it was going to do
um in an email on the 10th of june
no i would accept that criticism yeah
and uh whereas
um if you look at exdg 23
all of the matters that you asked mr
brett to attend
to were attended to the same day or the
next day
i would disagree with the issue about
staff wearing ppe but i do accept that
mr brett came back
very promptly and answered with those
points yes okay
um okay question number three then
um tell me about um
additional efforts made to empty the
bins or increase
bin capacity along the highs during this
period
okay again you'll have to excuse me if i
don't have the details to hand
um what i can tell you is that we uh
install um an additional
uh waste bin along the hive area uh
uh one of the large euro buttons yep
um from from the details that i can
recall
um it does get filled up quite quickly
and we've got additional connections in
place
collections in place to to empty that um
the stuff that we're picking up from
there is a mixture of stuff that's come
from people
bringing stuff from the outside other
shops and also some of the things that
they perhaps purchased from the jolly
sailors serving area
okay so you introduce one extra bin
and you somewhat increase the the
frequency of
collections okay
um and um
just the final thing then in terms of um
the steps that you took to um
investigate a specific causal link
between the issues that you've
raised and customers of
the jolly sailor sorry what what exactly
are you saying that you did to establish
that causal link rather than you know
it being a problem that may have come
from other other causes
so just repeat that question again yeah
so this issue about
the problems that you're complaining of
are they problems caused by customers of
the jolly sailor or are they caused by
people either a coming from elsewhere or
just nothing to do with any
premises um you know and just passing
through
what what efforts have you made to in to
investigate
that question bearing in mind how many
other premises there are you know in the
vicinity who can serve in particular
food but also
alcohol and non-alcoholic drinks um
so really it was it was down to the you
know local residents complaints
um where we've gone back to people and
said look you know
what are the you know what are you
complaining what's the circumstances um
they're the ones that supplied evidence
or alleged evidence about what they feel
is happening down there
um we've spoken to
mr about some of those concerns now i do
understand that he
he says that it's not all down to his
patrons
um and so really i wouldn't apportion
full blame to every single person that
goes through the jolly sailor and i've
not tried to say
again that everything is down to them
what i would say in terms of a causal
link
we have residents complaints that are
saying that it's their patrons that are
causing issues they've sent in evidence
that they're saying
is attributable to their patrons um
can i guarantee that every every
you know picture shows a direct link to
the jolly slider no but there are
certainly
some things that are attributable so i
would certainly say there's a partial
causal link in circuit
but you can't say how much no yeah
okay thank you chair have you come thank
you very much
you've obliged me greatly thank you well
i think i've been extremely lenient but
due to the importance of this i'm i'm
more than happy to um
to have indulged you um uh thank you
very much
um can i just clarify something mr
geller
can i clarify the fact that the licensed
cartilage includes this so-called upper
deck level
and that the premises license
includes uh the uh
sale of alcohol for consumption on and
off the premises
yes that's right thank you very much
okay thank you very much indeed um for
that
uh hopefully um uh we've got everything
we need
uh need from that um okay so now it's
the opportunity
uh for the license holder mr bet you can
now
um address the panel and call a witness
should you so fit
uh chair me again then i'm afraid um
mr brett as i say is sat beside me i
will pass the uh camera over to him in a
little while just to confirm that what
i'm saying is
um is accurate and if there's anything
else that he wants to add
um but you will hopefully have received
the representations that we submitted
last week that i think they were in your
supplemental bundle starting at page 51.
um i don't intend to go through every
word
of that but bearing in mind um
what uh mr quelch said about the fact
that
uh members of the public listening in on
this um
on this call and are not able to see
those documents i i think it is
um only right and proper that i do
summarize what those representations
say so let me start by explaining
yes mr brett he's the designated
premises supervisor
he lives in a building immediately
adjacent to
the jolly sailor his front door and
leads out onto the hive
so he is always around and he's very
much
um a witness of what goes on in the hive
area
he has held the premise's license or the
the old liquor license
in the in the old days um for the jolly
sailor for over 31 years he has an
unblemished
record during the whole of that period
so these allegations they cover the
period from the middle of
march until sorry the middle of may
until uh nearly the end of june 2020
throughout the whole of that period um
the jolly sailor was undergoing an
extensive internal
refurbishment um meaning that amongst
other things the toilets were out of use
but the pub has reopened to the public
it reopened fully to the public
insofar as it's allowed to on the 4th of
july and that
includes um the toilet areas um which
actually is the same day
uh mr brett um informs me that the
public toilets are there there or there
abouts
uh opened on the hide as well so
hopefully any allegations relating to
public urination are very much
uh matters um in the past
and of course mr geller has accepted
very wisely throughout this
um this hearing and before that in
in doing what it did namely serving food
and alcohol from
um the the patio area the upper deck
area
um the jolly sailor wasn't doing
anything unlawful
wasn't doing anything wrong because um
the licensed area
includes that patio area it's licensed
for the sale
for the off sales of alcohol and the
food
that was sold is not in fact a
licensable activity at all because
um it was only sold until at the latest
10 pm at night
and late night refreshment which is the
licensable activity under the licensing
act
um concerns food sold between the hours
of 11 pm and 5 a.m so
none of the food was a licensable
activity not within your
um jurisdiction um in any way shape or
form
um and um despite what mr geller says
about
um four um households having
complained it's actually mr brett's um
understanding that it might be nearer
near a two um households who have
complained but obviously we we can't
substantiate
um that because because everything is
redacted
um so we made some general comments
um on the evidence um submitted by mr
geller in support
of um the review application so that's
um exhibits exdg one to 33.
um and they um those
um general observations fall into sort
of five
simple categories if you like the first
one
is that um there are relatively few
individual complainants
and almost no independent verification
of the allegations that have been made
by those complainants
and to the extent that any relevant
authority whether the council or the
police
has proactively investigated the
allegations the extent to which they've
done so
um in my view is extremely limited
and that is concerning given as i say
the potentially devastating impact
that the outcome of this um this review
could have
um on the economic viability of the
jolly sailor
the second general point which i know
i've already labored
um in my cross-examination is that
there's no evidence
to establish an express causal link
between the issues complained of and the
jolly sailor
as opposed to that um long list of other
outlets
that um were able to uh
sell um items food and drink
alcohol and non-alcohol and two members
of the public
all within a quarter of a mile um radius
of the
um of the hive area and without any
investigation
um into those causal links um it really
isn't at all clear
in my submission why mr geller has
sought to apportion
um sole responsibility or even primary
responsibility to
the jolly sailor other than any one of a
number of other
premises that might have been in
inverted commas responsible
um and the third point is that um
against the background that mr geller
accepts that at what the jolly sailor
was doing was lawful um what he hasn't
been able to satisfactorily explain
um is what the jolly sailor could have
done but didn't do
to mitigate the matters of that were
complained off even assuming that there
was evidence to show that it was the
jolly sailors
in inverted commas fault as i've already
said
um neither mr mrs brett nor their staff
have got any jurisdiction
over what customers do once they leave
the cartilage of the premises
by contrast of course um the police
and council officers have very extensive
powers which i hope i've
um outlined in some of my uh questions
um and what's interesting about that is
that
um actually mr geller well knows this
because
in the only formal letter um
that was written to the jolly sailor in
advance of this review application
that's
his exhibit exdg 11.
none of the measures um that
he perhaps now says uh should have been
taken but weren't taken
um were actually raised as steps at
which he said
the pub should have been taking but
weren't taking there was nothing about
um you know stopping people um littering
there was nothing about stopping people
urinating there was nothing about
um trying to control uh people when they
left the premises it was all about what
was happening
within the cartilage of the licensed
premises
and as i've explained in
in these submissions and when we were
looking at exhibits ex dg22 and ex dg
23 the steps that were recommended
uh to mr brett by the council were taken
um
almost immediately and of course there
will always be examples
um uh particularly in terms of um ppe
um where individual members of staff at
individual times are not wearing ppe
um but as we've i think already
identified
um ppe at the time was not mandatory and
so mr
uh mr brick couldn't have enforced uh
the mandatory wearing of
ppe all the time in any event and of
course the other thing to say about ppe
is that
one of the great advantages of the way
that
um this premise is decided to set up
to do takeaway sales was that it did it
in the open air where the risk of
transmission is far
far more limited than it would have been
had those takeaway sales been
happening from indoors or inside a hatch
or anything like that the
the the flow of air would have meant
that the risk of um
of transmission of the infection was in
my submission
negligible so the fourth general
observation is the point that i've
already made and so i won't labor it and
that in contrast to
um the uh the the measures
um that mr brett was able to control and
did take
um if you contrast against that the
measures that the council and the police
were able to take
but didn't take even something so simple
as putting up
extra signage on the highest which was
promised on the 10th of june
uh by mr geller still hasn't happened
and it's now the 28th of
september so the council hasn't really
covered itself in glory in terms of
responding to these
um allegations and instead what it seems
to be doing um
is trying to put the blame solely on a
licensee
who doesn't have the authority to do the
obvious
things that might have made a difference
here and of course the final
general point to make is that actually
the most beneficial and contextualized
evidence
that we have about what was actually
going on down at the hive
um are the two video clips um
now i heard members of the um
subcommittee talking about those
um those clips immediately before i um
or immediately as i came online
um this afternoon and i don't know the
extent to which you've all been able to
view them
and just so you know i've been able to
view them but i couldn't hear any sound
on any of them so i don't know anything
about the
um the apparently rude word that was uh
said at the end of i think it was the
second clip the one inside the vehicle
um but in my submission the most
important and significant thing
uh about those two video clips which i
would certainly
ask members of the committee to view
very very carefully
um before making your decision today is
that
um they show uh the jolly sailor
complying with its legal
responsibilities there is obvious
evidence of social distancing
of ppe wearing there is in my submission
very good evidence actually also of
social distancing
um in and around the hive by by everyone
who's
um circulating uh in that area of course
it's a
it's a curious um side effect of
um social distancing that
um the more people um observe
social distancing rules the busier
an area will seem because they will
stretch out
over a larger uh space
by maintaining social distancing so um
what um in ordinary times in
pre-coronavirus days
might have been a a crowd of 15 people
that that might take up a very small
area
and will suddenly with social distancing
rules take up a much larger area
and will have the side effect of making
an area look much busier than it
actually
is so um
members of the committee um my
submissions then go on to a detailed
response to the allegations
um and this is the bit that i invite you
particularly to take as mr
brett's evidence and i will as i say
hand over to him
uh in in a little while just to ask him
to confirm that what i'm saying
is um accurate um but
i'm going to ask you to look at the
supplemental
bundle of evidence and
i had numbered that from page one
through to page
54 in the bundle that
i provided uh to the um
to your committee services team and i
think that's been renumbered now by uh
your committee services so it starts at
page
um 63 of the supplemental bundle and
goes on to page
115. so i'm going to refer
to pages one through to um 54
apologies uh if you if any of you are
getting um confused as to what document
i'm referring to please do
um speak and i will i will try and tell
you
uh what number it might be in your
bundle but um what
what the bundle starts with pages one
two eight are some general
um photographs of the hive area all
taken during the period in question
and showing for the most part that the
area was quiet
largely deserted and not covered in
litter
um page seven um shows
the upgraded um social distancing marker
tape
that was installed following um the
exchange of emails on the 10th of june
2020 that's the ex g22 and extg 23 that
i've previously
referred you to and
um page 8 shows
the ice cream van so this is page 70 of
your bundle
at the bottom of the hill and there um
throughout the vast majority of the
photographs
um taken during this period and in my
submission
probably a very significant draw for
people to queue
at the hive hang around at the hive and
enjoy an ice cream on a hot sunny day
um so those are just some general
photographs and then
um page uh pages nine to twelve
are some photographs showing the um
refurbishment that was going on um at
the pub
um during the period in question um
and uh you'll see some very extensive
work
uh being carried out particularly
ironically in the toilet areas that's uh
the photographs at pages
10 um and 11
but what's important to note about this
work is that it began in october 2019 so
way way before
um coronavirus was a thing and so
not something that um mr brett and his
team had any control over in the context
of what was going on
during coronavirus and and the the um
the the extent to which they might have
been able to make toilet facilities
available
um to users of the take away facilities
during this period they simply couldn't
because there weren't any toilet
facilities
within the premises even had people been
allowed to go in to use them
and of course the other thing to say
about this refurbishment is that
um it's incurring an expenditure in the
region of 180 000
pounds um which is a massive
um vote of confidence uh in um a long
established
uh licensed premises um which
uh in my submission contributes greatly
um to the vibrancy um and enjoyment that
people take
from uh the hive when they come and
visit throughout the year but
particularly
on a summer's day and of course um
it's fair to say that mr brett and mrs
brett would not possibly
um have invested um that sort of money
uh in these premises um had
uh uh and then deliberately taken action
and that would have put that um uh that
that license
and the and the ability to uh to
recuperate that
investment
we're in danger of straying again uh we
are concentrating on
the licensing act and whether the
licensee
complied with the licensing objectives
uh his investment in the pub is laudable
uh but not relevant on this particular
occasion
um i've got councillor siddhl wants
point of order is it any different from
what's been mentioned in councillor
civil
uh no it was that exactly that point
we're going off completely
yeah it's got nothing to do with what
we're looking at today so it could be
uh yeah could mr seedy please focus on
the key matters
and his evidence yeah mr celia i think
the point's been made twice now
um okay celia you are technically a
witness on behalf of
of uh uh the license holder um
and i'm sure uh that members would just
like to ask mr
uh mr brett a couple of questions yes of
course before we before we move on
um i i would just like to uh you
mentioned the fact that there is
uh evidence and videos that social
distancing is being observed
uh by the customers um i would just draw
your attention and and i would like a
straight yes or no answer no
um no elaboration on the the uh the
photograph on page 48 of the pack
can you just tell me yes or no are the
customers there
bearing in mind the queen's is closed
are those
customers in your view exercising social
distancing
yes or no please uh sorry i'm just
turning to page 48.
i've handed that to mr brett because
he's the witness not me
uh no you're you're you're mr brett's
witness um
because mr mr brett's representative and
i'm very happy to speak on that basis
but i'm not his witness well i
just i'd like a straightforward answer
to a straightforward question are
people shown in that photograph
exercising social distancing
because you've made the point that
customers
uh on on the whole uh are
behaving and exercising social
distancing while at the pub
what i would say about that is that the
people shown in that photograph
and we don't know where they've come
from or what they're doing there are
are gathered in small groups
and there are distances between the
small groups so you can see
just to see i can see people with drinks
in their hand i think it's their
assumption
uh that in the vast majority of cases
social diseasing isn't being observed
but i will leave that that point
made uh because mr and i accept the fact
that um
off the premises mr brett has got no
jurisdiction over that
um yeah but thank you you you raised the
point sir so i thought i would come back
now um has anybody got any questions
they would like to
sorry i i i haven't completed my
uh submissions if you if you're
determined to cut
if you're determined to stop me then all
i would say is
that they are relevant to the to what we
are discussing
and and that is whether yes
he has followed the licensing objectives
okay well let me let me try and
carry on then if you don't mind i was
going to
turn to um pages
um 13 to 16
uh no sorry 13 to
18 of the uh bundle that i submitted so
this is pages 75 to 79 of the
supplemental bundle and just say
here's the evidence of skips uh being
used at the premises and being used
principally but not exclusively i accept
for the disposal of
waste generated by the um
the outdoor operations the takeaway
facility
and collected from the hive so when mr
brett says
there was routine litter picking um this
is the evidence that we have
of it and i will and i will leave you
two uh
to to look at that um then uh the the
photographs from
pages 19 um to 30
so that's page um 82
90 taking the steps by and large that
council officers had advised him to take
um so that's um that's those
um photographs um
my submissions go on to explain um the
um
the steps um not taken uh by the council
i won't reiterate those
um and then the photographs from pages
32 to 38 show some general views of the
area particularly um on um
sunny days and of course the period that
we are talking about may and june we had
some very lovely weather particularly
um at the weekends um and what i want to
particularly draw to your attention but
i would
invite you to look at all of those
photographs and note that broadly
speaking
people will be outside of the immediate
control
of uh mr brett and his team because
they're on the hive and they're on the
street
are socially distancing they're socially
distancing in small
groups the one photograph that i want to
draw particularly to your attention
um is um the
the photograph um at um
page 37 so that's page 98 of the
supplemental bundle
which is the queue of customers uh
waiting to be served from the takeaway
going up
church street and what what i think this
photograph
demonstrates is that um
when people cue in a socially distanced
manner
it looks like there's an awful lot of
people queuing because of the gap
between them
um i've counted tried to count the
number of people in this photograph
a number of times and i've come up with
a number of about 16
and what they appear to be doing is they
appear to be cueing
in socially distanced family groups so
maybe couples
maybe couples with children but but
broadly speaking you can see that there
are
um there is a good good behavior there
um
by um customers of the uh pub
mr salee you you've made you're you're
making points that you've previously
made
uh in your cross-examination of mr
yeller
okay if you if you you know i i'd like
to just move on to mr
very briefly can i can i can i just want
to keep going over old ground again and
i want to
to keep this really focused on on these
licensing objectives because
that is to
uh determine whether the laws in respect
or the guidelines in respect of pbe
social distancing
or anything else have been broken this
is specifically
compliance with the licensing objectives
okay well all right um let me just
bring your attention to um the
specific representations by mr brett
concerning two
incidents that that form uh part of uh
mr geller's
uh evidence firstly this alleged fight
on the 24th of may
2020 and then and then secondly the wake
up candidate
can i stop you just very briefly because
you've made a point that licensees are
not responsible for what happens
off their premises i would correct you
in that they
are they have a responsibility they are
breaking the law if they
knowingly serve somebody that is
intoxicated they are
also uh responsible if they knowingly
serve somebody who's going to
subsequently drive which is clearly off
the premises so
um just because things happen off the
premises does not absolve the licensee
uh from his licensing objectives and i
would say
particularly given allegedly that a lot
of this
anti-social behavior happened in view
of the licensed premises you know i
think we have to bear that in mind
um had people have gone off to the prom
and done all of these various
uh activities uh it would have been a
different matter but most of it and
we've seen quite clearly from the
photographs with the exception of the
litter in the
in the uh planters on the high street
which i appreciate we can't attribute to
to the jolly sailor um
things have to be taken into account uh
are in the immediate vicinity of that
licence premises so
you know i really want to get on track
and i'd like to get this concluded as
soon as possible please
okay um well in that case let me just
ask you to consider mr brett's response
to the allegations about the fight on
the 24th of may
and the wake on the 19th of june
essentially neither of those things
having anything to do with the pub
and in terms of littering um i've
already explained
littering was a general problem in the
vicinity
but there is little or no evidence to
link it
expressly to um
the the jolly sailor and actually lots
of evidence
that we've produced to show that it was
nothing to do with the jolly sailor
um it was uh litter that simply didn't
come from
uh the premises at all because it wasn't
the sort of litter uh the
the sort of products that um that the
pub sells or the type of packaging that
the
that the pub provides it's uh its food
in
um and then i'd ask you um to
consider very carefully the witness
statements um
in support of mr brett's position
they are witness statements that begin
um
at page um 105.
so 104 of the supplemental bundle
and they consist of a mixture of um
statements from members of the public
who have approached
mr brett he hasn't approached them and
witness statements from members of staff
at the pub um who explain um the
efforts that they took and some of the
grief to be fair that they
received from some aggrieved local
residents
and then in terms of um the relevant
representations received
and two things briefly to say about
those
the first is that uh two of them are
supportive
of um the jolly sailor which in my
submission
on a premises license review application
i've never seen it before i think that's
extremely unusual
and extremely welcome and again mr brett
will confirm
um that he doesn't uh personally know
either of the individuals who have made
um
relevant representations in support of
um the pub
um and in in so far as um the
representations
from uh the other uh individuals mr and
mrs gibbs
and mr golding are concerned i'm not
sure if you know
um this because i think the the the
bundle that i have seen that you've been
provided with
um of the relevant representations have
been redacted to a greater extent than
the copies that i was initially provided
with
um so it might be i think it is
important for me
um to outline which of the
representations
i'm talking about and so i'm talking now
about the representations of pages
39 and 40 of your um
i think it's your supplemental bundle um
these are the ones beginning
uh dear mdc we are in full agreement
with the need to review the premises
license granted to the jolly sailor
church street malden
and then the further representation at
page
38 and that's the one that begins i
fully support your application for the
review of a premises license at jolly
sailor church street
all i want to say about those and
particularly about the ones at pages 39
and 40
is that these representations are made
by a couple
who own a property on the hive
and it runs a bed and breakfast
how they run a bed and breakfast service
from
their home as such uh the jolly sailor
is a direct competitor
to them because the jolly sailor has
three bed and breakfast rooms that were
refurbished
um in 2018. so um
there is a degree um of uh commercial
competition going on here uh mr lee i
think i think you've made your i think
you've made your point and i think
i mean the problem of course chairs
mr sealy no i appreciate that fact um
and uh i i'm going to draw you to a
close there because i think
during your cross-examination of mr
geller and your statement certainly made
um made a very thorough uh job in
support of
the license holder which is of course
what you're there for
mr geller you now have an opportunity to
cross-examine mr seeley
and members have an opportunity to ask
mr seeley questions
um really only one question it just
relates to
um the
pictures um and i'm just getting to the
page number there with me
okay so if i refer to page
88 um the pictures of the
the serving areas um can i just check
when is mr able to confirm when he put
up additional signage
on those serving areas i'm gonna i'm
gonna
swing the camera around so that you can
see him on the day i spoke to you
and uh the subsequent email those will
put straight up
let's put straight up and from the looks
of it and i'm looking at the picture
page 95 um
it's not very clear because it's it's
sideways but where of where i've moved
it
um just to confirm
the larger sign that's taped to the edge
of the
the serving area is that a menu or is
that a
covered warning that's that's a price
list
that's the price list there's two so
there's one smaller bit of paper that's
actually hanging off the end of the
table
the sign says notice right and were
those hand written or printed
printed they were printed okay
um can i please ask
why they weren't made more robust or
prominent
bearing in mind the concerns we had
about and i accept the fact that
uh the questions have been raised about
what the council can do but in terms of
the
premises we put up 15 of the signs on
the front of the
cottage on the gazebos on the hill and
under the windows of the jolly
as you're walking down so 15 signs
were very prominent okay were those
handwritten or printed
or printed and were they were they
laminated in any ways that they were
robust or were they just
facilitated initially they were
certainly tapped then they were
eliminated in first and cell cell types
okay thank you mr keller do you have any
other questions
uh no thank you uh members
do you have any questions completely
before i'm going to ask mr
brett to make a statement
yeah mr uh councillor siddal
uh i just wanted to check are we asking
questions to mr bro
and to mr sealy at the same time well
um technically to mr seely
at the moment i don't have any questions
until i've heard from mr brett
okay thank you very much indeed members
any other members before we get mr brett
to make a statement
thank you you're going to have to
twiddle your computer again mr celia i
would just make a um
a statement for um for
members uh good afternoon uh good
afternoon mr brett thank you very much
for attending so this is your
opportunity and
clearly mr seeley has um uh provided us
with a great deal of information
um in in defense of this uh
hearing so and now's your opportunity um
to say anything you wish and then
members it's quite clear i'll
like to ask you a couple of questions
thank you mr chairman i'd like to point
out
that i've owned the jolly sailor for
over 30 years plus
we don't have trouble down there i have
zero tolerance to drugs zero tons to
underage
we shut the place early we don't have
loud music
outside um effectively we spot we're
respectful to our neighbors
i've been here an awful long time and
the two neighbors that
have orchestrated this particular
debacle
have a grudge to settle okay a lot of
people did appear down there but they
weren't coming to us
they were using that as a walk through
to the prom they were coming off for the
prom
the amount i witnessed personally people
walking down with crates of beer
coming out first stop cans of stella
which we don't sell cans there was more
product
down there then we could have ever hoped
to sell
give you an idea our average take on the
day was about a thousand pounds
so if you work it backwards our top line
product being four pound fifty
if everybody put one single item is only
220 people
most people bought multiple items so we
were controlled
i couldn't control what was going on the
key side i had no jurisdiction over it
the trouble with the incident with the
fight one came down church street
holding canastella
one came from nook street the fight
started up in the in the town outside
uh the tanning shop and they decided to
carry on
it was all over a dog and a uh
ex-girlfriend when the police turned up
they uh turned the people just turning
around sat and explained to the police
obviously went over to them
exactly what had gone on and they said
right it's a squirmish that was the end
of it
but this was nothing to do with alcohol
we had sold nothing to do with the
people who were on the pr
who bought from us on the subject to the
funeral
as soon as we saw the numbers the the
personal concern was the local um
should we say personality they stopped
at every pub in the town going through
and he had a lot of she would say
followers
the it was that i believe he was one of
the drinkers out of work
because the warwick was shot and they
couldn't gain access to that they
decided to go on the key side
as soon as we saw what was happening we
killed it from our respect
we can't be responsible for people going
walking down there and also walking down
there with absolute
little cases of beer
okay is that that's your that's your
statement mr brett is it thank you very
much
thank you thank you um councillor siddal
uh now's your opportunity to uh answer
your question mr brett
thank you chairman uh mr brett when you
decided to open
what did you see as the impact of you
opening
earlier in the year we we looked at it
there was a number of people gathering
down there the kiosks
were opening um there was people going
down there with food uh we i i lived
down there
and there's people turning up at like 12
o'clock 1 o'clock in the morning with
domino's pieces
uh kebabs all sorts of things was going
on down there
we thought okay if we were we could
offer a service
it would serve the local community and
99.99 of the people we're happy what
we've done
we've done things lawfully we've done
things correctly we made
we didn't serve people were intoxicated
and in the intent
the people who were intoxicated with
nothing to do with us did you did you
see
in terms of the condition of the of the
premises though
did you see any impact in terms of
opening when your premises
were in that condition from my
understanding and i took the lead from
malden council whose toilets were closed
if the toilets had been opened i
couldn't allow people on the premises i
took my lead from malden kansas on that
one
okay so so the fact that you couldn't
provide them with toilets you didn't see
a problem with that
um to be honest no one in the area was
open
and then i looked at other people doing
exactly the same operation
um in kent in essex and they were they
didn't have tools facilities
okay okay um yeah
you said that you live on the premises
and you you obviously witness things
what what did you do in terms of taking
the initiative to solve some of these
actions what what did you try and do
for example when we after the first
couple of days we realized that there's
a problem with litter
so then we make sure every hour one of
the girls or the boys went out with
black sacks
picked up all our stuff and and to a
certain degree certain other people's
stuff
and we put it onto our premises into our
skips
so that was one problem we saw
if the numbers got too great we shut
early if
um for example i i
i my office is in darfur so i normally
go start first thing in the morning
so i'd come up about six o'clock and
there'd be rubbish there
not down to us and i think mr geller can
confirm that i had a conversation with
him
about instead of doing the collection
emptying the pins at 10 in the morning
why didn't they do them very early in
the morning so the bins were empty
i had a 24 minute conversation with him
about it
okay how many times did you shut early
oh more times the latest we were open
was eight o'clock
but how many how many times did you say
okay there's too much disturbance
there's too much of a problem
so how many times did you actually do
that over that time period
i suppose about 10 times that i
considered it they were the wrong type
of people down there
okay okay and
so you can also point out i've been in
more than a long time
i know the people that i considered
long-time people were people that would
not be allowed in the jolly
okay what would you say that you've
learned from this
well i've learned from this effectively
that god will be we have another
situation like that
we won't be operating in that particular
manner we'll be very guarded in what we
do
and to the effect of we've carried on
the outside operation
all the way through after the perhaps
opened it's still used
because a lot of people don't want to be
inside everybody buy a drink or a burger
or a cup of tea or coffee
and sit away from people so we're still
offering that service
of course during the winter now that
will limit it down
we're only going to operate on the
saturday and sunday if the weather's
permitting
so really the thing is fizzled itself
out anyway
okay so in in terms of how you're
operating at the moment
people are inside your premises as well
as outside that's correct
okay so uh if you go back to when you
decided to do the opening
and open from your your terraces
uh would you say that that was would you
do the same thing again
in hindsight i would alter it okay and
how would you alter it
and effectively we wouldn't go to the
hours that we were
you know we would only probably operate
between twelve o'clock and six o'clock
outside
we wouldn't if there was um groups
um gathering then we'll just cease it
okay all right thank you very much thank
you
thank you councillor siddel uh any other
members wish to ask
mr brett a question
uh mr brett i just want to answer a
couple when
when uh the full lockdown was
uh let's lightened um
it wasn't lifted and licensed premises
uh had
some sort of leeway to reopen given the
fact that the queen's head is right next
door
uh to you did you not think that perhaps
you should get your heads together and
come up with a
class to open jointly to to uh fourth of
july
officers walking around i
uh tell you exactly what time it was at
four o'clock i went over and saw gavin
at the queen's head
i said what time are you going to shout
tonight will we be in line with you so
we agreed to strategy if shuttle at the
same time
but what but you you you didn't get your
heads together prior to
reopening in in your takeaway we never
we never saw any of the queen's head
staff unlike my staff that weren't
furloughed
i think they were all furlong there
wasn't anybody living on the premises
that i could see
the i think the owner of it lives at the
anchor at
danbury so i think the premises are
deserted
i don't i can't confirm that but that's
mine
but uh you know given the fact that then
you were
you were in full knowledge that yours
was likely to be the only licensed
premises
open in that particular area um
that's not actually correct because it
could say
like the little ship club what they were
the members there were walking in and
out
and they were sitting on the case side
drinking booze from the little ship club
they said they had they had some chairs
they'd take chairs out of there so that
was going on
next door that's a that's a members club
mr brown isn't it and i'm just thinking
you know
you you you were probably the only pub
within a you know
within a reasonable distance so there
was every expectation that
you know the people that have been
gasping for a drink for you know
several weeks were were likely to to
come and frequent
and i've got absolutely you know there's
absolutely no problem you have a
business to run
and uh you know provide you that you
work within the law
uh that's that's you that's your
prerogative uh
and you know let's face it we all know
how hard it is for the hospitality
industry and particularly now
um and no nobody's nobody's here to
criticize the fact that you chose to
open uh you know what what we're here to
look at
is is whether you took due regard of the
licensing objectives now
you're a long-standing um licensee and
personal license holder and and that's
that's you know i'm not going to
you know embarrass you by getting you to
recite the licensing objectives because
i know you know them off by heart
but at any stage while you were open
well while you were
in this fairly unique position being the
only licensed premises and were were you
know
busy no reason why you shouldn't be busy
did you at any time stand there
and think that you may be in
contravention of one of those
four licensing objectives that is
prevention of crime disorder public
safety
prevention of public nuisance or
protection of children did you at any
time look out and think oh crikey if it
goes on like this
i may be contravening one of those
objectives i'll give you an example
of one of the things that i did it we
put draft lager on
it brought the wrong immediate wrong
people down there we seized it that day
so i was careful with what was going on
if i considered that something was going
to be a problem it was like the problem
with the funeral as soon as i saw
what was going on that was enough and we
did it in such a way
if we just shut and gone it would have
caused decorations so we we wound it
down very slowly
not to unwind any situation up another
particular day
um there were some people on the on the
key side they
they brought bottled champagne down they
had a little beat box
so where we've been accused about the
music we didn't have any music
effectively or we we had background
music
um on behalf of co very low so that the
staff could hear what people say when
they were ordering
but on the key side there was always
something with a beat boxer an ipod
um i i got woken up one one night one
o'clock in the morning
and there was um some um i'm gonna say
foreign and shouting and screaming
dancing around something
in some language i didn't recognize and
i'm sure
these were things were happening because
the weather was so pleasant people were
turning up there all sorts of odd hours
which were completely nothing thank you
mr brett
so so basically yes you
you did think that some of the things
you were doing we're going to cause a
problem but you took what you saw as
being the correct mitigation
problem that's absolutely fine that's an
answer to the question
uh councillor stilts you'd like to ask a
question and then we'll wind up i think
uh yeah yes thank you mr chairman um
actually mr brooks just answered my
question i was going to ask him
about the allegation of music making a
party type atmosphere down the pro
uh the down the key and whether they did
actually play
loud music at the premises at any time
thank you yeah i mean this is
if i explain all our music is what we
call background music
so it's not um you know more jazzy type
music
it's done quietly because with that type
of pub we've never had loud music
now somebody accused me of being on the
key side
dancing well let me tell you i can
barely walk i've just had to
uh i've been i mean i've drive for eight
months i still can't walk straight
so to dance i wish only i could wish to
dance at the moment
all right so this is the nonsense that
was coming out do you do you have
external speech because mr brett
loudoun yes we do we do have external
anchors and there's two out there
okay all right thank you yeah of course
right if you look at some of the emails
i sent
the people at 32 um
members of the little ship club we've
been a variance with them over then or
it's not making those copies of emails
to environmental health
about their loud music going on to the
middle of the night even though they're
only licensed
which whilst that period of history is
continuing it is no longer
the same um during that period
um both in terms of um the extent to
which we are now in a lockdown
or not in a lockdown um but also
uh and very significantly to the extent
that we are
now entering the winter period um rather
than the subject
i've heard today a little while ago um
the reality is that um the takeaway
facility
um that is the subject of this
application is not going to be operating
anything like the capacity or the number
of days that it was
previously mr brett explained to me that
yesterday
the outside bar area took about and
twenty quid
um in takings um uh yesterday
yeah on so on a sunday
um in the winter so this is this is an
issue it was before
toilets are now open everywhere as well
and so really any um attempt that you
might take
um to take steps for example to remove
the permission for off sales
is very much um closing the stable door
not after the horse has bolted but after
the horse has
um returned to the stable and sat down
and is munching away on its oats
obviously we we fully fully appreciate
exactly what you've been saying
these are strange and challenging times
we are looking back on the evidence that
we have had for what happened in
in may and june we're not looking
forward into what may happen
in in the next six months so just if you
if you we
we we we totally acknowledge
the fact uh and that you're making some
of the actions open to us may compromise
mr brett's business and um we are fully
cognizant with the seriousness of the
decisions that we're about to make so
please rest assured we will take
everything into account fairly
thank you um what i what i would say
just in
in finishing is that of course um any
steps that you decide that you
that you might think are appropriate to
take today
they can't stop the sale of takeaway
food because that's not
late night refreshment so it's not they
can't stop
well they could stop but but but in my
submission it would be entirely
disproportionate to stop
on sales of alcohol because there's no
evidence that any on sales have caused
um any of these problems and i don't
think mr galla has ever said suggested
that
um so that all you could realistically
do
is stop um the the off sale
of alcohol but food could still be taken
away uh people could still consume
alcohol in the premises and on the
inside
um so i i think you need to bear in mind
that um
that realistically any kind of response
to
um any kind of proportionate response uh
in any way shape or form to the
allegations uh complained of is not
going to
um to result in no activity happening
um at the pub at all and of course
and again i'm sorry to labor the point
but what you have to be satisfied
about because you're acting in a
quasi-judicial capacity
so you need to be satisfied on a balance
of probabilities
that the problems complained of by mr
geller in his submissions
are problems that are expressly causally
linked to the jolly sailor
and and in my submission you can't be
satisfied of those things
um and in any event the action
that mr geller seeks you to take namely
the removal of off sales
um a won't won't solve any uh particular
uh problems complained of because of you
know the
the fact that people can still uh get
off sales from other
other premises no license in 2005 along
with mr bet so i'm fully i know
what are and what are not licensable
activities
uh yeah and no so please be assured that
you know we
we are um as a committee not not wet
behind
the gills we we are very experienced so
um and you know i can i can absolutely
assure you that that we will
um give a fair hearing thank you
is that the conclusion let me just turn
to mr brent and see if there's anything
else he wants me to say
i'll stop there thank you much
appreciated thank you very much
indeed mr geller it's now your
opportunity to make a a final closing
statement please
thank you councillor uh the main uh
statement i would make is that
um we believe that the serving areas on
the upper decks and the ability to
provide off sales
are what's um at the heart of this um
i've done my best to try and present the
evidence available to me
uh in in a way that sort of explains the
difficulties that we were facing
um and the challenges relating to kovid
if members believe that um
the operations on the upper deck uh
represent a risk
of kobe transmission um two members of
the public
if if they believe that there's a
risk to children if they believe that
there's possibility of nuisance arising
from the operation on the upper deck
um then we would strongly support
um some sort of conditions to try and
mitigate that um
it's certainly part of uh you know wider
respiration that we try and
um improve the situation down there
and really just to just
to ask members to bear in mind it was
never the council's intention to try and
put the jolly sailor out of business
this is not where we're heading
um but we do believe that there is a
better way for them to operate uh other
than the capacity under which they're
currently operating thank you
thank you mr geller members before we
close this meeting to make our
deliberations have any other members got
any comments
they wish to make please no thank you
chairman
no thank you chairman councillor stilts
nothing thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed
uh so this meeting will now close uh we
will
uh re-complain the members of this
committee only will reconvene to
uh make our decision uh mr celia as you
know
you will be notified within five working
days of this hearing
uh the result uh that we come to
and uh of course you are uh able to
appeal against any decision within 21
days and as you know the appeal
is determined by magistrates rather than
rather than ourselves thank you very
much
for putting together such a
comprehensive
support of mr brett thank you mr geller
for your uh
for your hard work uh and um
as i said we are now going to close the
meeting and uh
reconvene to make our deliberations
thank you very much indeed
thank you